[Musique]
la cupidité sont est à l'origine du
démantèlement de ce trafic de cocaïne
entre la martinique et la france les
prévenus qui voit j'ai très souvent par
le dernier vol de la journée dans un
système bien rodé échange est
semble-t-il des cubis de rome acheteurs
duty free par des cubis de cocagne de 10
kg avec la complicité d'un policier de
la paf un business qui sombre fructueux
et qui permet d'engendrer des gains
conséquents
certains d'entre eux souhaitant
poursuivre un grand train de vie
tenteront de faire passer les cubis de
30 kg l'étau se refermera très
rapidement et mettra un terme à ce
business illégal
c'est ainsi que la suite une information
judiciaire contre x
les zones de l'actrice de nos terres et
de l'eau serti de fort de france
agissant sur commission rogatoire d'un
magistrat instructeur procède à de
nombreuses arrestations d août 2016 de
la première vague
david s 37 ans désigné comme le passeur
est interpellé à orly en possession de
plus de 30 kilos de cocaïne dans la
foulée lewis qui serait l'organisateur
du trafic
we know m présenté dans ce dossier comme
le logisticien et bruno f sont aussi
interpellés
leurs auditions permet de procéder à de
nouvelles arrestations quatre personnes
le 15 novembre 2016 dont un agent
d'exploitation d'une compagnie aérienne
si certains ont reconnu les faits
d'autres les conteste les huit prévenus
seront à partir de mardi et ce durant
trois jours devant le tribunal
correctionnel de fort-de-france